البدايه من تطورات الحرب الاوكرانيه حيث
اعلن قائد قوات فاجن الروسيه السيطره على
بلده يقديني شمال بخموت السلطات المواليه
لروسيا انها تسيطر على اكثر من نصف
المساحه الاداريه الاقليم وشرح كمدونيسكا
الموالي لروسيا في تصريحات صحفيه اشار الى
ان القوات الروسيه تسيطر على اراضي جديده
تتوسع في دنيا يوميا واضاف انه من غير
المناسب الحديث عن مواعيد محدده لانتهاء
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه مضيفا ان كميه
الاسلحه التي تزودها الدول الغربيه تؤثر
على ذلك
فيما نفت هيئه الاركان العامه للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه مزاعم مجموعه فاغنن
الروسيه بالاستيلاء على قريه يغديني شرق
اوكرانيا وقالت هيئه الاركان للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه قالت ان روسيا تواصل
اليوم تركيز هجومها على طول خط الجبهه
باكمله